that the next question that your Prophet
Muhammad peace be upon him is he
physically dead or alive and we have to
agree physically mhammad sahi wasallam
dead he B in Madina is isaam Jesus
Christ peace be upon him is he
physically Dead or
Alive we have to agree that he's alive
the Quran says in Surah n 4: 158 that
Allah subhana waala has raised him up
alive so who's greater a prophet whose
dead is greater or a prophet the life is
greater they ask the question but they
don't give you the reply they let your
mind think they use as Muslims as
punching bags as D mats and we can't
even open our
mouth see doing dawa is very easy if you
read the
Quran with
understanding and if you keep your mind
open doing dawa is very
easy Allah says in the Quran in Surah Al
Imran chapter number 3 verse number 64
say oh people of the
book come to Comm in terms as us and you
which is the first
term that we worship men but
Allah that we associate no partners with
him that we erect not among ourselves
Lords and patrons other
than if then they turn
back Witness that we are Muslims bowing
our will to Allah subhana wa tala this
verse of the Glorious Quran Surah al-
Imran chapter number 3 verse number 64
according to me is the master key as far
as dawa to non-muslim is concerned is
the master key for dawa it
says come to commment terms as us and
you which is the first term Allah that
we worship none but
Allah that we associate no partners with
him
and if you
see the tapes and the lectures that I've
given all these questions have been
answered how true dawa has been
explained it's so easy only thing you
have to do is open your mouth the
non-muslim society can be divided into
further three categories one is a
category who is religious
there are in the non Society in the
western Society there are since majority
of Christians there is a small
percentage who are
religious they are Christians and they
follow the scripture the
Bible in other societies like in India
where majority are Hindus there is a
small portion a small percentage of
Hindus who are religious who follow the
scriptures the best way to Da with these
people
is
come to Comm in terms as and you which
is the first
term that we worship none but Allah we
have to speak from their
scriptures trying to prove about one
Allah subhana wa tala the best thing
about dawa the most important aspect is
proving about Oneness of Allah subhana
wa tala all the other aspects are
secondary if you cannot convince a
non-muslim
about about monotheism it is useless you
may speak to him about other aspects of
Islam but if he yet continues doing shik
it will never be forgiven shik is the
biggest sin in Islam which Allah will
never forgive unless he repent before
death and this way how to do dawa based
on the words of the Quran I've have
dealt in various of my talks
similarities between Islam and
Christianity similarity between Islam
and Hinduism and how to
dawa for example living in the Western
Country where the majority claim to be
Christians though a small percentage are
religious in Bridging the gaps with the
Christians I've given the talk on
similarities between Islam and
Christianity where I've mentioned there
that Islam is the only non-Christian
Faith which makes it an Article of Faith
to believe in Jesus Christ peace be upon
him we believe that he was one of the
mightiest messengers of Allah subhana wa
ta'ala we believe that he was the messah
translated Christ we believe that he was
born miraculously without any male
Intervention which many modern day
Christians today not believe we believe
that he gave life to the Dead with God's
permission we believe that he healed
those born blind and lepers with God's
permission the Christians and the
Muslims we are going together but one
may ask the then where is The Parting of
vs The Parting of ways
is there are many Christians who say
that Jesus Christ peace be upon him he
claimed
Divinity he said that he was almighty
God in fact if you read the Bible there
is not a single unequivocal statement in
the complete Bible there is not a single
unambiguous statement in the complete
Bible where Jesus Christ peace be upon
on him himself says that I am God or
where he say worship me I am a student
of Islam and compi religion and I read
the Bible there is not a single
unequivocal statement not a single
unambiguous statement in the complete
Bible where Jesus Christ peace be upon
himself says that I am God or worship me
in fact if you read the Bible Jesus
Christ peace be upon himself said it's
mentioned in the Gospel of John chapter
number 14 verse number 28 Jesus Christ
PE upon himself said that my father is
greater than I Gospel of John chapter
number 10 verse number 29 my father is
greater than All gospel of Matthew chter
number 12 verse number 28 I cast out
Devils with the spirit of God Gospel of
Luke chapter number 11 verse number 20 I
with the Finger of God cast out Devils
Gospel of John chapter number 5 verse
number 30 I can of my own self do
nothing as I
hear I judge and my judgment is just for
I seek not my will but the will of my
father anyone who says I seek not my
will but the will of almighty God he's a
Muslim Jesus Christ peace be upon a
Muslim and it's clearly mentioned in the
book of Acts chapter number two verse
number 22 that e men of Israel listen to
this Jesus of Nazareth a man approved of
God amongst You by wonders and miracles
which God did by him and you witness to
it a man approved of God amongst You by
wonders and signs and Miracles which God
did by him and you are witness to
it so if we read the scriptures we can
prove from their scripture that Jesus
Christ peace be upon him he never
claimed
Divinity he was the messenger of
almighty God we can prove from the
Bible about the coming about the Advent
about the prophecy of the last and final
messenger Prophet Muhammad sallu Ali
wasallam you can give a talk on
that it's mentioned in the Old Testament
in the book of Deuteronomy chapter
number 18 verse number 18 in the book of
Isaiah chapter number 29: number 12 in
the Song of Solomon Chapter number 5 ver
number 16 in the New Testament in the
Gospel of John chapter number 14 verse
number 16 in the Gospel of John chapter
number 15 ver number 26 in the Gospel of
John chapter number 16 ver number 7 in
The Gospel of John chapter number 16 ver
number 12- 14 you can only go on giving
references from the
Bible where the prophecy Muhammad Sall
Ali wasallam is
mentioned time doesn't permit us to talk
about these aspects you can refer to my
video cassette on similarities between
Islam and Christianity or Muhammad
sallallahu Ali wasallam in the Bible
similarly if you're living in non-muslim
society where you have
Hindus you can come to Common terms as
far as their scripture is concerned and
our scriptures
concern if you're living with Buddhist
it's the same if you're living with Jews
it's the same technique so this is as
far as one category of non-muslim is
concerned those who are
religious in today's world especially
the Western
World though people
claim to be Christians very few are
actually practicing
Christians they are more
impressed with science and
technology and most of them practically
The Atheist they do not believe in
God so how will to Da to
them if I meet an atheist and if he
tells me that there is no God the first
thing I'll do is I will congratulate
him you will wonder why is Zakir
congratulating atheist the reason I will
congratulate atheist is because most of
the
non-muslims they are
non-muslims because of the
parents most of the human beings they
follow the parents blindly he's a
Christian because father is a Christian
he's a Hindu because father is a Hindu
many Muslims are Muslims because the
father is a Muslim this atheist is
thinking his parents may be religious
but he's thinking he does not
agree in the gods with the parents
worship so he says there's no God and
the reason I congratulate The Atheist is
because he has said the first part of
the Islamic
shahada there is no God so half my job
is
done the only thing I have to do is
illah which I shall do
inshallah see the atheist as I told you
Surah Al Imran 3:64 is the master key
for
da come to commment terms as been us and
you there are many Muslims ask me that
what is the commonality between the
atheist and the Muslim I said the first
part of the Islamic Shah there is no
God because half my job is done to
another non-muslim who believes in a God
first I have to prove to him that the
God is worshiping is
wrong and then I have to talk to him
about Allah subhana wa tala here half my
job is done he has already said there is
no God only thing I have to do is ill
which I shall do inshallah now most of
these athe I I told you they have become
atheist because they believe in science
and technology which they feel is so
advanced Ed and they become atheist and
after congratulating him I ask him a
question that suppose there's an
equipment there's an object which no one
in the world has ever seen no human
being has seen if it is bought in front
of you and if the question is asked that
who will be the first person who will be
able to tell you the mechanism of this
equipment of this object if I ask this
question to an
atheist that an object or an equipment
which no human being has ever seen in
this
world if it's bought in front of that
atheist and if he asked the question
that who will be the first person who
will be able to tell you the mechanism
of this equipment what reply can you
give
you what reply can he give
you
Creator manufacturer some may say
Creator some may say manufacturer some
may say producer some will say inventor
what whatever they say it will be
somewhat similar just keep it at the
back of the mind either the will tell
you a Creator a manufacturer a producer
an inventor it will be somewhat similar
or maker keep your back of the mind and
continue ask him the next question that
how did this universe come into
existence so the atheist will tell you
that we have come to know that initially
our whole universe was one primary
nebula later on there was a secondary
separation a big bang which gave rise to
galaxies the Stars the planets the Sun
and the Earth on which we live this they
call as the Big
Bang if you ask the question of the
atheist when did you come to know about
this big bang he will tell you 30 years
back 40 years back we came to know how
the universe came to exist in the big
bang you ask him the question what
you're talking about the big bang is
already mentioned in the Quran 14400
years ago in Surah Amia chapter number
21 verse number 30
do not the unbeliever
see the heavens and the Earth were join
together and we cloth them as under what
you're talking about the big bang is
already mentioned in the Quran 14400
years ago who could have mentioned this
in the Quran 49 years ago The Atheist
may say maybe it's a FL don't argue we
have to ask him the next question that
what is the shape of this earth on which
we
live so he will tell you that previously
the human beings they believe that the
Earth was flat it was in 1577 it's a
Francis Drake he sailed around the earth
that he proved that the Earth was
spherical we ask him the question the
Quran
mentions the spherical shape of the
earth 1400 years ago inah chapter number
79 verse number 30 where Allah
says
and thereafter we have made the Earth XG
shape the Earth we live in is not
completely round like a ball it is
geosphere shaped it is flattened from
the poles and the egg that is referred
in the Quran Thea one of its meaning is
an expanse one of the meaning is an egg
it specifically refers to the Egg of an
ostrich and if you analyze the shape of
the Egg of an ostrich that too is
geosphere in shape imagine the Quran
speaks about the
geospheres that who could have mentioned
this in the Quran so he will tell you oh
maybe your Prophet Muhammad sallallahu
Ali wasallam was intelligent man don't
argue continue you ask him the next
question that the light of the moon is
it its own light or reflected light so
he will tell you previously we thought
that the light of the moon was its own
light recently we have come to know that
the light of the moon is not its own
light but it is is the reflected light
of the
sun yesterday in science means 40 years
back 50 years back 100 years back Quran
mentions 1400 years ago in Surah fan
chapter number 25 verse number 61 that
blessed is he who has made the
constellations in the skies and plac
therein Sun having a light of its own
and moon having borrowed light having
reflected light who could have mentioned
in the Quran 14400 years ago that the
light of the moon was not its own light
but it was a reflected light but it was
borrowed light again The Atheist may say
maybe a prophet Muhammad sallallah Ali
wasallam was a very intelligent person
don't argue with him
continue when I was in school I passed
my school in
1982 I had learned that the sun was
stationary it did not rotate about its
own
access is that what is mentioned in the
Quran I said no this is what I learned
in school I learned in school that the
sun was stationary it did not rotate
about its own access but the Quran
mentions inia chapter number 21 verse
number
33 it is Allah who has created the day
and the
night the Sun and the
Moon each one traveling in an orbit with
its own motion the Arabic word y bahun
describes the motion of a moving body
and it says that the sun besides
revolving it even rotates about its own
axis and today science tells us with the
help of an equipment we can have the
image of the sun on the tabletop and the
sun has got black spots and it takes
approximately 25 days for these black
spots to complete one rotation
indicating that the sun takes 25 days to
complete one rotation who could have
mentioned this what I learned in school
23 years
back now the sign says it is
wrong and the Quran has mentioned this
1400 years ago who could have mentioned
this in the Quran The Atheist may give a
long pause don't wait for the reply you
can keep on continuing today scientists
tell us that our universe is expanding
the same message is given in the Quran
1400 years ago in Surat chapter number
51 verse number 47 that we have created
the vastness of space the expanding
Universe in the field of hydrology it
was Bernard pacy in 1580 who was the
first person who described the present
water cycle which we learned in school
previously we did not know about the
water cycle the first person was a
Bernard pacy in 1580 that he described
that the water evaporates from the ocean
forms into clouds it mov into the
interior it falls down as rain and the
water table is replenished now this
water cycle is described in the Quran in
great detail in several places in Sur Z
39 :s 21 in Sur room CH number 30 ver
number 24 in Sur CH number 23 ver number
18 in Sur CH number 15:22 in Sur chapter
number 24:43 in Sur room chter number
30: 48 in Sur chter number 13 verse
number 17 in Sur chter number 7 verse
number 57 in suran chter number 25: 48
to 49 in Sur F 35 ver number 9 in Sur 50
verse number 9 11 in Sur 56: 68 to 70 in
Sur M 67 vers number 30 in
CH number 86 verse number 11 you can
keep on giving references only of water
cycle mentioned in the Quran 1400 years
ago the Quran speaks about the water
cycle in great detail you can talk for
several minutes on each verse talking
about water cycle who could have
mentioned this in the Quran 400 years
ago and the atheist would be silent keep
on there are several scientific facts
mentioned in the the Quran the Quran
speaks about
geology today science tells us that the
mountains give stability to the Earth if
the mountains were not there the Earth
would shake the Quran says in Surah naah
chapter number 78 verse number 6 and S
that we have created the Earth as an
expanse while and the mountains at
Stakes today's science tells us that the
portion of the mountain you see above
the ground is a very small portion The
major portion is deep within the ground
like how when you put a tent peg in the
ground small portion remains on top The
major portion goes down and these roots
of the mountain they give stability to
the Earth the Quran says in Surah Amia
chapter number 21 verse number 31 that
we have created the mountain standing
firm on the earth lest it would shake
with
you in the field of
oceanology we knew previously that there
were two types of water salt and sweet
but we did not not
know that why these two water did not
mix Quran says in Surah fan chapter
number 25 verse number 53 that it is
Allah who has created two bodies of
flowing water one sweet and the other
salty though they meet they not mix
there is a barrier between them which is
forb to be trespassed today after
science Advan we have come to know that
though one type of water flows into the
other type of water it loses its
constituents and gets homogenized into
the water flows this homogenizing area
the Quran refers to as Barak an unseen
barrier which SS have discovered today
and Quran has mentioned 1400 years ago
in the field of biology the Quran says
inia chapter number 21 verse number
30 we have created every living thing
from water who could have believed 1400
years ago that every living creature is
made of water today science has
confirmed that everything is made from
water Quran says in Surah n chapter
number 24 verse number 45 we have
created every animal from water Quran
says in Surah fan chapter number 25
verse number 54 we have created every
human being from
water in the field of botony Quran says
that even the plants have got Sexes male
and female in Surah T chapter number 20:
53 which we came to know recently Quran
says that every kind of fruits are
created in pairs in Sur chapter number
13 verse number
3 in the field of zoology Quran speaks
about the lifestyle of the animal in
Surah Anam number 6 verse number 38
Quran speaks about the lifestyle of the
bees in Surah Nel number 16: 68 and 69
Quran speaks about the spider in Surah
anab 29:41 about the ant in Surah namal
chter number 27: number 77 to8 and all
these aspects of the spider of the ants
of the Beast we have come to know
recently and Quran mentions in detail
1400 years ago who could have mention
this Quran speaks about medicine that in
the honey there is healing for humankind
in Surah n chapter number 16 verse
number 68- 69 Quran speaks about the
production of milk and the circulation
of blood in Surah Nel 16: 66 and suron
chapter number 23: 21,400 years ago
which we have come to recently Quran
speaks about medicine about physiology
about embryology the various stages of
the human development it described in
detail in Surah M chapter number 23:
number 12- 14 Quran speaks about
genetics about the sex responsible for
the child in Surah naam chapter number
53 verse number 45 Quran speaks about
the fingerprinting method in Surah
chapter number 75 verse number 3 and 4
after every scientific fact mentioned in
the Quran ask the atheist who could have
mentioned this in the Quran 49 years ago
and his reply would be the Creator the
manufacturer the maker the inventor this
this Creator this manufacturer this
maker this inventor we Muslims we call
him as
Allah even to an atheist we can prove
about the existence of Allah subhana wa
ta'ala with the help of the last and
final Revelation the Glorious
Quran we are not using
science to prove Allah subhana wa ta'ala
the science is the yashik of the atheist
our yashik is the Quran we are using our
yashik and comparing with his yashik and
trying to prove that our yashik the
Glorious Quran is far superior to your
science so these type of non-muslims to
dawa based on the similarities if he
thinks science is Ultimate we use
science and try and get science and the
commonalities in the Quran and try to
get him closer to
Islam Allah says in the Quran inah
chapter number 16 verse number
125 invite all the of th Lord with
wisdom and beautiful preaching and argue
with them and reason with them in the
ways that are best most gracious we have
to Da with and with husna today the
times have
changed especially after
911 we find that the Muslims on the
receiving end there is vent propaganda
about Islam on the international media
whether it be the international
newspapers the international magazines
the radio broadcast stations the
television channels
there is virent propaganda about Islam
they are bombarding people with
misinformation about Islam it's the duty
of every Muslim that he tries to remove
these
misconceptions there are various styles
of doing dawa the most commonly used is
that you speak a thousand good things
about Islam to a non-muslim even if you
speak a thousand good points about Islam
to a non-muslim and even if he agrees
with those thousand points yet at the
back of his mind he'll think ah you are
the same Muslim who's a
terrorist ah you are a fundamentalist ah
you are the same Muslim who marry more
than one woman ah you are the Muslims
who subjugate The Woman by keeping her
behind the veale these few negative
points at the back of the mind will
prevent the non-muslim from accepting
the beauty of
Islam what I personally prefer that
whenever I meet a non-muslim I ask him
upfront what do you feel is wrong with
Islam with your limited knowledge
whether right or wrong what do you feel
is wrong with Islam and I make him
comfortable you can ask any question on
Islam you can criticize Islam you can
attack Islam I will try my level best to
reply and in the experience that I have
of more than a decade in the field of
dawa I have come to know that there are
about 20 common questions with the
non-muslims have regarding
Islam and when they ask you three or
four questions invariably it falls
amongst these 20 common questions so if
you know the reply to these 20 common
questions as by the
non-muslims based on Quran Hadith and
their scripture with reason logic and
science even if you cannot convert him
at least you can neutralize him you can
remove the animosity which is there in
his
heart I've written a book called The
replies to the questions asked by the
non-muslims and these question arise
depending upon how the media portray
Islam and today the number
one question is regarding the Islamic
word
Jihad it was number five on the list
previously after 91 it became top of the
charts the others have come behind but
it's yet
there time will not permit me to reply
to all these inshallah in tomorrow's
talk I will deal more with this topic
about terrorists about fundamentalist
about extremist Etc in detail I'll just
tell you how to reply to the top of the
charts that is Jihad as far as this word
Jihad is concern there is not only a
misconception among the non-muslims
there's even a misconception among the
Muslims most of the people think that
any War fought by any Muslim for any
reason whether it be personal gain
whether it be for power whether it be
for money it is called as
Jihad Jihad does not mean any War fought
by any Muslim for any reason whether it
be for personal gain for personal money
for power Jihad comes from the Arabic
word jahada which means to strive which
means to struggle in Islamic context it
means to strive and struggle against
one's own evil inclination Jihad also
means to strive and struggle to make the
society better Jihad also means to
strive and struggle in the battlefield
in self-defense jiad also means to
strive and struggle against operation
so Jihad basically means to strive and
struggle many
non-muslims mainly the orientalist they
translate the Arabic word Jihad as holy
war and unfortunately many so-called
Muslim Scholars and inverted Comm even
they translate Jihad is holy
war in Arabic if you translate holy war
into Arabic it would be har mad and if
you read the Quran nowh is the word har
madasa mentioned in the Quran neither it
is mentioned in the Hadith so Jihad does
not mean holy war holy war was first
used to describe the
Crusades with the Christians they killed
tens and thousands of human beings in
the name of religion that Holy W was
used to describe the Crusade
Unfortunately today it is used to
describe Jihad which is totally a
mistranslation Jihad basically means to
strive it means to struggle one type of
jihad can be kital
that is fighting which
is fighting in the way of Allah subhana
wa tala but that too has got various
rules and regulation which you can refer
to my video cassette Jihad and terrorism
and Islamic perspective which I've dealt
in detail about this and I'll just give
an example how to do
dawa last year i' had gone to States
last year before last i' had gone to
States in Los Angeles
and traveling alhamdulillah M different
parts of the world in various countries
including the Western Country several
times USA Canada Australia and other
parts I was prepared the way I'm dressed
up with a cap with a beard with a coat I
was sure that in the US Customs I'll be
asked for
interrogation so as I went to the
immigration they asked me the question
that why have you come here I said that
I've come to receive an award that's me
what award I said award in service of
humanity what do you you do I said I
spread truth Jesus Christ PE me speak
the truth and truth shall free
you and after asking many questions I
see to it that I pick up every opport to
dawa while going to the Customs I
purposely mention that I've come for a
convention like I came this time and
I've come to receive an award so they
asked me okay go and open your bag when
they open my bag they saw a tape of mine
a video tape that time video tapee I
taken J and
terrorism so the custom officer he asked
me that do you believe in Jihad I said
yes I believe in Jihad Jihad means to
strive and struggle Jesus Christ peace
be upon beli in Jihad he said no no I'm
talking about do you believe in fighting
I said yes even Jesus Christ peace be
upon believed in fighting if you read
the Bible in the Old Testament book of
Exodus chapter number 22 speaks about
fighting Book of Exodus chapter number
32 speaks about fighting Book of Numbers
Chapter number 31 speaks about fighting
Jesus Christ PE be upon mention in the
Gospel of Luke chapter number 22 he said
that take the sword and go and
fight so they said but that was fighting
against EV said yes that's what the
Quran says too we have to fight against
the evil and in this way when I started
doing dawa the custom officers all
gathered together and there was a small
mini lecture I only told my host that
don't worry I'm just doing dawa in the
immigration and the customs and Sir can
we ask you one more question sir can we
ask one more question and to cut the
story
short you should grab every
opportunity and you should try and turn
the tables over give the answer which he
expects the least but I don't want
everyone to do that otherwise they may
get into
problems as far as dealing on the higher
level where to turn the tables over you
have to be careful otherwise you get in
a problem then they say okay Dr Zak told
me
that depending upon the
situation you can prove from the Bible
that what they attack about the Quran
the same thing is mentioned in the Bible
when I'm in India I use a different
strategy the master key is the same but
I speak about bhagwat Gita I speak about
Mahabharat when the Hindus say that the
Quran is wrong it speaks about fighting
I tell them that there are more verses
of fighting in Mahabharat than the
Quran but then they tell me no but this
is a war between truth and falsehood I
said same is what the Quran says it is a
war between the truth and falsehood then
the Hindus tell me we have got no
problem with the
Quran and if you read bhagwat Gita which
is the most popular scripture of the
Hindus in chapter number one verse
number 43 to
Arjun there's a fight between the
cousins the Pand and the K Pand the five
brothers kavas uh total 100 brothers so
Arjun one of the pands in the
battlefield he puts his weapons on the
battlefield on the ground and he says to
Shri Krishan who's god of the Hindus he
tells to Shri Krishan I would prefer
being killed unarmed rather than to
fight against my
cousin immediately next few verse
chapter number two verse number two and
three Shri Krishan who's supposed to be
the God he tells Arjun how could such
impurities come in your
heart how could you be so important he
calls him
important and further bhagat Gita
chapter 2 verse number 31 onwards he
says it is the duty of the chhatria to
fight if if you don't fight you will not
go to the Heavenly
Planet it will take you away from the
Heavenly planet and blessed are those
chatas who get an opportunity to
fight and most of the critics of
Islam they point out ACC common Hadith
of mammam ofari volume number four in
the book of
jihad number 46 where Prophet M wasallam
said
that if a mujah goes to the battlefield
if he's killed he will get jna he'll go
to heaven if he comes back alive he will
get the booty of this world he'll get
the wealth of this world and many
critics whether Christian Hindus they
point this Hadith and say what kind of
religion is this is talking about Jihad
fighting and you go to heaven what kind
of religion is this I tell the Hindus
that if you read bhagwat Gita chapter
number two verse number 37 SRI Krishan
tells
Arjun that oh Arjun rise and fight if
you are killed you will go to SW
Heavenly planets if you come back alive
you would get the wealth of this world
it is the verbum translation of s bukari
volume 4 Hadith number 46 so when these
critics of Islam especially the Hindus
like Arun shuri I wonder that they
haven't read the own scriptures and
they're pointing F in the Quran the
moment to give the context and speak to
them the complete misconception is
washed away t
come to commment terms as been us and
you so it's the duty of every Muslim
that he conveys The Message of Islam to
the non-muslims dawa is f but
unfortunately today we Muslims we give
excuses for not doing the
job when we tell them why don't you do
dawa they say inshallah when we get the
knowledge we start doing dawa the time
will never come if you think you'll wait
till you become like sh and then start
doing dawa the time will never come I
beloved Prophet said it's mentioned
inar propagate even if you know one
verse even if you know one verse about
Islam as long as you know it correctly
you have to do your job at least the
Muslims know there is one God at least
tell
that we know about muhamad sallallah ali
wasallam is the messenger he's the last
and final messenger of Allah subhana
tala at least tell
that if they ask you the question how do
you prove it if you don't know come back
and do your homework I give him the talk
on his the Quran God's word proving that
Allah subhana tala I've given the talk
on Muhammad sallah Al in the various
World religious scriptures come home and
do your
homework in this way inshallah Allah
will help you and you'll be able to
convey The Message of
Islam some Muslims come and tell me the
brother Zak first we want to make the
musl P musl we want to make the Muslims
practicing Muslims and then we'll do
dawa to the non-muslims I say the time
will never come our beloved Prophet
Muhammad sallallahu Ali wasallam he
himself could not me his own Uncle do
you think you're better than the
prophet in the farewell
pilgrimage proph M wasallam he told the
sahabas there were 110,000 sahabas that
did I deliver the message to you and all
of them said Bak yes verily you have
done it the prophet told them that all
those are present here deliver the
message to those who are not present
here and out of 110,000 sahaba more than
100,000 sahabas they were buried outside
the Arab land doing what making making
musl Paka musl making Muslims practicing
Muslims they went to do
dawa in
Madina there were Muslims who did not
come for the compulsory congregation
Salah did not come for the jum Salah the
prophet said he felt like burning their
homes yet he sent Messengers to the king
of abenia King of Persia king of Yen
asking them to accept Islam he did not
say first St make all the Muslim 100%
practicing Muslim and then do
dawa doing dawa is on every Muslim it's
compulsory but many of the Muslim tell
me that when we start doing dawa to the
non-muslims they tell us to mind your
own
business I tell them if any non-muslim
tells me to mind my business I will say
that's what I'm doing it's the duty of
every Muslim to mind other person's
business as far as de is
concerned so by doing dawa I'm minding
my business that is my
business it is the the business of every
Muslim to mind other person's business
as far as de is
concerned it is f on every Muslim to
convey The Message of
Islam and one of the criteria to go to J
as Allah says in the Quran in Sur Al
chapter number 103 verse 1 to3 where
Allah
says by the token of time man is well in
a state of loss except those have faith
those who have righteous deeds those who
exalt people to truth that is to dawa
and those who exalt people to patience
and perseverance for any human being to
go to Jenna minimum four criteria are
required Iman righteous Deeds dawa and
exalting people to patient and perance
if any one of these are missing you
shall not enter Jenna you may be a very
good Muslim you may be offering five
times Salah you may have gone for Haj
but if you don't do dawa you shall not
enter Jenna only dawa is also not
sufficient patient all four are equally
important IM righteous Deeds da and
exalting people to Patient perseverance
if you do not do dawa under normal
circumstances you shall not enter Jenna
if Allah wants to forgive you and put
you in Jenna that's his business as
Allah says in Surah 4 vers 116 and verse
number 48 that Allah will never forgive
the sin of shik any other sin if he
pleases he may forgive you so if you
don't do dawa and Allah wants to forgive
you that's a different question but but
under normal circumstances according to
if you don't do dawa you shall not enter
J and especially to those Muslims who
are living in a non-muslim society it's
an it's compulsory for every Muslim to
convey The Message of Islam to the
non-muslim and Allah says in the Quran
in no less than three different places
in Surah chapter number 9 ver number 33
and Surah fat chapter number 48 ver
number 28 and Surah saf chapter number
61 verse number9 Allah
says Allah has sent his messenger with
guidance and the religion of Truth so
that it will prevail over all the other
religions over all the other isms over
all the ways of life whether it be
christianism whether it be Judaism
whether it be Hinduism whether it be
Buddhism whether it be communism whether
it be atheism Islam is destined to
supersede all master them all
how much the mus don't like it and
enough is Allah as a witness Allah
subhana wa ta'ala has promised that his
Dean will prevail will supersede all the
ways of life Allah subhana tal does not
require you and me the rubish that we
are Allah himself is sufficient to make
his Dean Prevail he does not require you
and me the rabish that we are he's
giving us an opportunity to do a
prophet's job and do on a prophet's
reward I would like to end my talk by
giving the cor of the Glorious Quran
from Surah
chapter number 41 verse number 33 which
says who is better in speech than one
who invites to the way of thy Lord Works
righteousness and says that I'm a
[Applause]
[Music]
Muslim